thank you I'd like to personally add my
thanks to Dave Dave Roger did he did
Dave leave by now but I wanted to just
thank you again for all that you and the
Hillman Foundation has done this this
really is phenomenal we'll see what what
that vision has come to I I'm very
excited about this particular panel and
the set of amazing panelists that we've
got to to speak with you that the topic
of it of the panel is the science of
smart cities what is a science
well I starts with an understanding of
the components and systems and
terminologies that those within the
science used to describe what's going on
it starts with a better understanding of
the interaction dynamics of what's going
on between those components and and and
how they form systems and how they
behave you start to understand what is
healthy normal good versus what isn't
the science helps you to start to
understand that it's it you start to
understand what is known and what is it
known and you focus on the unknowns and
and and you accept the knowns as facts
and then we start to ask what does our
science predict so I look forward to the
comments of our panelists and ask them
to each it briefly introduce themselves
and talk for a few minutes about their
view on and what their work they're
doing how it relates to this concept of
the science of smart cities and please
start I look forward to your comments
let's start with Alex shoulder Shova and
and then we'll go down the line have
each of our panelists introduce
themselves thanks Jim
so first of all it's a pleasure to be
here I'm
system professor here at the Heinz
College my official title is statistics
in public policy my background is in the
first and I'm working on the ladder when
I think of the science of smart cities
what comes most naturally to my mind and
my disciplinary training is the data
science of smart cities and I'm really
proud of some of the work that we've
been doing especially with our county
collaborators for instance in the child
welfare system trying to use the data
that's available to provide a more
strategic delivery of services to some
of the most disadvantaged members of our
community to give you a sense of why I'm
so proud of this work we back in
November had a team from Denmark come
here to learn from what we were doing so
I think when Denmark comes to you to
learn about how you are using data to
improve your child welfare system that's
a big win now there are lots of
challenges here many of them are
technical many of them are policy but
again this is extremely exciting work
that's really picking up and to iterate
all these points it starts here and then
everyone else tends to follow right
Kristin Kirk
so hi I'm Kristin Kurland and I am a
joint professor between the School of
Architecture the Heinz College and I
have a courtesy appointment in civil and
environmental engineering so that kind
of gives you an idea of the
cross-disciplinary nature of what I do I
want to talk a little bit about
collaboration because I think that
collaboration is one of the key factors
here we talked about that a little bit
earlier this morning my world is
collaborating not only between what we
have here at the at Carnegie Mellon but
also externally my research is health
and the built environment and I do a lot
of collaborative projects with
physicians at UPMC and Children's
Hospital of Pittsburgh I just wanted to
mention a quick example I recently did a
project with physicians looking at why
kids don't show up for well visits and a
clinic here in Oakland and we did a lot
of the data analytics I do speak and
geospatial analytics and I use tools to
identify what neighborhoods those kids
were coming from but what was really
important in this project was we
identified that and then we were trying
to solve the issue as to why they
weren't shown
we had preconceived notions about
transportation and other issues that we
we thought that we knew what it was but
what we ended up doing was convening a
facilitator to actually go into the
neighborhood work with the the actual
patients that weren't showing up in the
families and we found out it was
actually a trust issue and it was a
trust issue with not seeing the same
physician every time that they were
coming to the clinic so I think that we
talked a little bit earlier about how do
we engage citizens in our research and
our projects and it that's probably one
of the more difficult things to look at
especially when you're looking at cases
like this so this is one of the things
that I think that you know we do well at
Carnegie Mellon and we do a lot of this
science well but how do we then engage
the citizens and I want to mention one
thing that I think we have another
secret sauce to Carnegie Mellon and
that's interdisciplinary but I would say
it's our students as well and so I want
to give a shout out to the students that
we have there's probably far more
projects than any of us know about that
are happening here at Carnegie Mellon I
see it in my classrooms and I see the
engagement that the students have at
different levels so I think that that's
something that we have to look forward
to to engaging our students and then
just very quickly the other work that I
do is with architecture and planning and
add on Carter mentioned our project a
little bit earlier today but we're
working on some really interesting
cross-disciplinary projects looking at
3d visualization and and using different
kinds of tools to help inform citizens
as well my colleague Jose de Moura thank
you so I'm a professor of the Electrical
and Computer Engineering and the College
of Engineering and I am what I'd like to
tell you about is first of all the
cities on a personal basis provide
actually a great opportunity to work
with people that I actually hadn't had
the opportunity before so when we
started Manuel and I were on sabbatical
at NYU adcast we interact a lot with
and physicists that were looking at
problems of cities which was a surprise
why were these people concerned with the
high energy physics and particles in
accelerators and so forth why were they
looking at cities and their take was
looking at cities from a scale point of
view looking as which which is an
interesting point back to to CMU it
turned out that it also provided the
personally to me to go to a college that
I never worked with before I think which
was the your College architecture the
College of Arts I guess and we don't
Carter that is somewhere there and it
has been a pleasure because we talk
technology and he doesn't really talk
about arts but talks about the cities
and how the cities are organized and the
how whatever we do should impact impact
the cities and so Don Shawn came from
from Seville and the Heinz and the
Schumacher from ECE we have been for the
last couple of years brainstorming of
how do we look at the city and looking
at the city from an environmental point
of view looking at the city from the
built infrastructure and this paths that
also are in the city which are the
humans and we took the point of view of
looking at that system of systems as we
heard this morning looking at it from
the point of view of mobility so don't
look at everything focus on mobility and
even focusing on mobility you get to see
lots of different dimensions so mobility
not as a social mobility or economic
mobility but mobility as try as
transferring people from A to B and
actually when you look at mobility and
look at the city from that point of view
you start seeing all the relay the Intel
relations between these different facts
and the the point of view we have taken
is don't look at a particular point of
the city
or another point or a succession of
points look at the city globally look at
the city as the whole extent in space
and in time and try to see a time
o'clock in the morning when people go
from to 79 all the way to downtown or
maybe to Oakland try to see all those
people coming from all different
directions
croelick criss crossing each other can
you understand what what's happening can
you as this morning was was suggested
can you predict something or or if there
is a stone tomorrow can you take some
remedial action and try to ease how
people will flow so that's the point of
view that we have been taking looking at
the city how people populate how people
impact the environment of the city how
the the built environment impacts how
people move around try to understand
that thank you
Thank You Josie Satya from thank you Jim
my name is Satya I'm a professor of
computer science and I work on a new
emerging area called edge computing
which was really pioneered by my
research group and is now being embraced
widely all of you know what cloud
computing is edge computing is taking
the power of the cloud but placing it
very close to where data is being
gathered in real time think of large
numbers of video cameras widely deployed
perhaps multiple video cameras per
automobile capturing in real-time data
processing it extracting information and
fusing it what can you what can this do
for an area like a city what it can do
is effectively help you create a nervous
system something that helps you sense
process and hopefully intelligently
react to phenomena as they are occurring
as Joe say and others on this panel have
remarked there's a tremendous amount of
science that people have already built
up surrounding urban areas and and
similar similar and geographic settings
but most of that has been done in batch
mode where the data is gathered
processed the results are obtained next
week and the paper published a few
months hence transforming that into
actionable information that synthesizes
infuses high data rate sensor inputs
using algorithms that are today only
possible in the cloud is really the
focus with my work so in partnership
with a number of companies crown castle
which I believe is represented here in
the form of Chris bloom Lee
Verizon Vodafone direct you telecom and
others we are creating a living edge lab
in Pittsburgh and we already have
wireless antennas on campus in Oakland
and in Walnut Street in Shadyside and
that's an example of what Dave Rogers
was mentioning it took actual permission
from the city to install those things
and thanks to crown castle for doing all
the hard work on that so this is why
what I'm doing is relevant to smart
cities and I cannot think of a more
exciting opportunity thank you thank you
my name is Ben Melville loser and I'm a
professor in the school of computer
science currently they had the machine
learning department but I do have
appointments in computer science in
electrical engineering in the robotics
Institute so like they were saying we
were on sabbatical at New York at this
Center for urban science and progress
called cusp in its very beginning and I
got a chance of spending one year
talking in workshops with multiple
entities of the city the police
department the mayor office the trans
and Parks and Recreation sewage you name
it we met actually two with groups of
people that were responsible for a
variety of aspects of the city we
actually who actually took it very
seriously these workshops and these
connections with who were supposed to be
the scientists and the researchers Beit
physicists or computer scientists they
shared their problems and so I kind of
like well I when I was there I did a lot
of work with 3-1-1 data and all sorts of
like also trying to understand traffic
but what was more compelling to me in
some sense was the fact that I don't
know
it was the fact that in some sense there
were people involved in all these cities
that would need a lot of support from
data to make decisions I remember the
mayor approached cusp with the question
where should they build the new the next
100 kindergartens schools was it going
to be on the intersection of 120 second
where the second Avenue or down in 53rd
and 3rd and 7th Avenue and how we would
shoot these B and what would be the
impact of those decisions in the
functioning of the city so I thought I
mean and that is the longer a lot is
decision making along the lines of the
research I do in trying to automate
agents to make decisions by combining
data some kind of planning to achieve
goals and eventually actually making the
decisions but the aspect that I think
that I would like to emphasize with us
all here is that whatever we do in a
city more than processing data making
analysis creating an infrastructure
needs to be well justified for the
humans so there is this aspect in
machine learning in AI that it will not
help a city it will not help decision
makers if our systems are black boxes
that just say yeah thanks kindergarten
there and then the mayor or the humans
involved
in all these governance we'll ask why
and these machines will be black boxes
that say because I say or something like
this so that's the research I've done a
lot and I believe it will be part of
these automation of cities and the
automation of all these processing of
information and data and the support is
really to provide the interpretability
and the explanations that these data
analysis needs to provide and especially
to support decisions in cities which
cannot function without the involvement
of people governing them and so that's
one aspect that maybe it's common to
also doctor's office but I think for
cities in particular that so many
decisions are long-lasting so you cannot
decide I'm going to put this building
here and tomorrow yeah yeah by the way
I'm going to move it to the next corner
so this is a type of from a mathematical
point of view of decisions that are
different in a decision that the robot
or an agent does in turning left because
it can recover it can recover afterwards
in cities that these meetings with the
city of New York officers who were very
kind of striking for the long-lasting
decisions you decide to change the
traffic like that and it stays like that
you decide to put an building like
therein stays like that so I really
think that the explanation process and
getting input from humans and biases and
all sorts of like being in these
interpretability and explanation mode is
essential for the automation of a city
Thank You Manuela thank you for all to
all the panelists to kick this off my
plan by the way is to ask one or two
questions or have the panelists ask each
other questions and then open it up to
the to the audience the first question I
have is you know we've talked a lot
about the cities being you know systems
of systems and we'll the science be a
science of Sciences in other words is
this is the science of cities a pullet
is it a political science is it a social
science is it a physical science is it a
information science I mean I I think
parts of all those sign
are going to have to impact this science
of cities and will we ever get to a an
understanding of the nones of a city
that will allow us to be predictive as
jose said I think being predictive is
an important ability of a science does
anybody want to talk about that let me
start by making one point which is
especially important to keep in mind
when we're thinking about human services
and criminal justice and it's that data
is not neutral and data is not objective
if you think about the sort of data that
we collect on citizens at this point in
time and what we have available
historically this has been shaped by
decades of processes societal political
and many of those processes have been
discriminatory so if you're thinking
about even built infrastructure and
you're ruling out certain locations
because currently they do not look very
good it doesn't mean that that's an
objective fact about those locations or
those communities and it's certainly not
the case that just because you're
finding crime were you bothered to go
search for it that that's a practice you
should perpetuate so part of I think the
sciences of smart cities is making
better use of our data and an important
part of that is making sure that we
understand the process that generated
that data and the inferences that we can
draw that hold some value and which ones
are simply risking perpetuating the same
mistakes we've made before in other
words we want to be learning from our
mistakes not simply learning to
replicate them by the way I forgot to
mention that the solution to our project
with the no-show patience was to open a
clinic in the neighborhood where those
patients were located but I think a lot
of it too is communication
and you know we do a lot of this you
know if you look at the panel even here
we have many different areas that we're
working in and how do we communicate
that especially across areas that were
not necessarily affiliated with so I
think that when we look at the science
of this I would say yes to all of the
above that you had asked and I would say
plus more anymore they were not talking
right because I think that there is a
lot to this that again goes external to
other kinds of disciplines so I just
want to add one point I think you guys
covered
well but the unintended consequences so
as we were brainstorming with one of the
local communities and my emphasis as I
say is look at traffic and mobility and
how people go from A to B the person
from that community said well actually
we have no cameras so we couldn't look
at again but if you by any reason by
looking at ways or Google or whatever
can tell us the traffic can give us an
idea how to make the traffic ultimately
a traffic analysis on this particular
part of town that will help a lot our
police and I said what oh yeah because
we know that at certain hours certain
places certain patterns of traffic will
tell us about certain social activities
so there are these unintended
consequences and that's why
I think that we really need to get the
technologies with the social scientists
and with everybody else mm-hmm anybody
else want to touch on that or we could
open it up for can I mention one of the
sciences you didn't mention yes please
you didn't mention computer science hi
smart cities are very interesting
because they stress computer science
ideas in severe and new ways and from
that intersection arise many new
algorithms many new techniques and let
me in fact
pick up on the point that Josie just
made he mentioned traffic and ways and
so on so many of you I'm sure drive with
Google Maps and you see the coloring
that indicates how crowded a particular
areas that is done without any human
input ok it's done purely by
participating drivers having their
smartphones report GPS location
periodically and
that gets fused and the map appears so
completely untouched by human no
distraction to drivers works well but it
doesn't tell you why something is red is
it it's it relates to the point that
Manuela made a moment ago is it red
because it's just a temporary a car rack
that's going to be moved in a minute or
is it red because it's down from four
lanes to two and it's going to be this
way the whole week yeah there's no
information
now there's another company called ways
which was purchased by Google for 1
billion dollars B in 2013 this is how
valuable they considered it which
consists of people reporting information
gives you a lot more information but
it's distracting for driver has to do it
that's not very good we already have
distracted drivers could you get the
level of detail of ways without active
human intervention could I run computer
vision with you know convolutional
neural networks right at the point of
capture of the video data on a car
convert that into information such as
dead deer and left lane at GPS
coordinates X Y and transmitted in that
is the kind of new opportunities that
are that emerge when you try to apply
the computer science ideas to this kind
of domain and so to me I find this very
exciting not only because of the
potential to do good but I think to me
personally even more for the computer
science to be better because the
challenges posed are much greater and
there's a wide range of challenges I
don't want to dominate the the talking
here but we can go into that in response
to questions or further discussion I
think that I think I just want to pick
on the prediction and exactly on this
nonhuman aspect I think that one aspect
of the science is that we also need is
the sciences of a lot of of course the
machine learning the prediction and the
causality a lot of the things in the
actual cysts are about what if they are
counterfactuals what if we would do this
what if this would happen
a lot of prediction but driven by
specific questions it's not prediction
about only how the current dynamics of
the system evolves but it's about
predictions of where with the systems be
if something will happen differently so
you want to participate this particular
kind of system which is the city and I
pathi size what will happen if we change
these traffic what will happen if a
hurricane comes and blocks all the south
of the of Manhattan what will happen if
the parade of the st. Patrick's parade
takes over all 5th Avenue so there is a
lot of counterfactuals that people need
to solve and need to come up with models
of what happens and for those we can
have both also computer science and
machine learning solutions and
engineering in which we kind of can
simulate these very complex systems to
to try to stretch their sensitivity to
dynamics and to change so we can
eventually answer questions that help
people be ready for all these outliers
of the distributions because it seems
that everything that is like within the
average we are fine but when there is a
sandy storm when there is a big
snowstorm everything kind of the Cystic
collapse so the outliers in some sense
are things in which the technology can
make great contributions because maybe
we already have thought of those
situations if we train systems to be
able to think about counterfactuals and
that's like one area that I think it's
very important is this kind of like
simulation hypothesizing coming up with
models that enable us to reason about
counterfactuals very good at this point
I'd like to open it up for questions
from the audience
yes Ben
thank you my name is Bentley Biden with
Metro lab Network a question for whoever
wants to jump in and answer it um how do
you and your colleagues reconcile the
academic incentives I guess at the
various levels of progression within the
academic cycle with the fact that
challenges facing local governments and
communities are inherently very
cross-disciplinary and do you think that
academia as a whole is sort of well
incentivized to solve these kind of
challenges and what can we do to
encourage that kind of behavior going
forward I'll jump in and start because
my project is very much the eye on the
end of our project is can this actually
be implemented in the city and so I
think that that has to be thought out
when we do all of these projects and and
I think that the panel this morning
talked about this with the deans you
know how can we do this financially we
can't do any of this without the city
frankly we could do all of this research
but we can't deploy it so I think that
for me at least throughout all of our
project is we bring in the
interdisciplinary team that we need to
solve these problems but I think it's
also goes beyond that it goes to the
understanding of the different
disciplines we so much work in silos and
we may not understand so the project
that I'm working on has entertainment
technology students in the gaming world
working with urban planners and you know
we need to cross we need to cross
educate a lot of these projects as well
especially the interdisciplinary so I
was going to add to that that if there's
any university that could do well in
those terms its Carnegie Mellon right so
we already do this almost in our DNA
second point I want to make is you you
are correct that academia being what it
is to ask a junior faculty member to
spread himself or herself in by many
engagements which may not be directly
focused on all the obvious metrics of
academic success might be bad advice but
you know eventually you get to be a full
professor they don't tell you what your
full off at that point okay well you
hopefully have a few more decades left
and so there is no reason I look at my
immediate colleagues Manuela and Josie
and myself and many of the excuses that
one might say okay to to a junior
faculty member don't apply to us so I
think you're absolutely correct but
there comes a point when we have the
freedom we have the independence in
which direction we choose to go in is
ours to choose other questions well go
back to a question that Jim I thought
was trying to ask which is looking at I
guess the exemplary work done by each of
the panelists for example Josie focuses
on mobility for example so to me but
there is a higher level requirement of
kind of a compositional science which
takes individual scientific principles
in each silo so to speak mobility or
health or social welfare and so on and
then bringing those model science
together
don't overarching science where we can
actually explore the interactions among
these various models if you want so I
guess my question is is that notion of
composition science hopeless to achieve
this is within the realm of reason I
guess we can accomplish that in five
years ten years twenty years that's one
part of question the second part is that
even from where you stand today are
they're very difficult problems that
need to be solved it's just a matter of
time and resources are there some
problems that we do not know how we can
solve today and therefore they become
fundamental challenges for the future
yes try to focus oh I have to do things
to say first some years ago so looking
at cities I was talking again with one
of the physicists and I start saying oh
maybe we should look at at cities and
try to understand the DNA of the city
and so forth and he said oh go and
Richard Inger Schrodinger in the 40s
Schrodinger's
physicist Schrodinger in the forces
physicists gave a talk to whoever or
wherever where he kind of predicted DNA
so he said we look we should look at
just like in physics there are particles
and particles follow certain rules and
the physical rules and so they engage
among themselves and form these very
complex systems we should look at the
equivalent of particles he was totally
wrong by the way but an equivalent and
tried to explain biology from the point
of view of interactions of these very
elementary components and is fascinating
actually to to read Schrodinger's
lecture that he gave so start thinking
maybe we should do the same with cities
but I'm not sure dinner so I can't think
like him so I take the exactly opposite
point of view and that's again my friend
down there over there and he said why
are you looking at cameras and look and
Counting cars and all that why are you
doing that that's useless so ok don't
then tell me what what should I be doing
you should be answering the questions
that the city or the town asks you ok so
let's go back to the town let's go back
bring those people in what is it that
you want and that's where they come and
say well we are concerned that they are
gonna build a shopping mall a shopping
center five miles away and our city our
roads are are already clocked so what's
going to happen what's the impact so
rush I want I kind of gave up on that
DNA stuff it's very nice but my limited
understanding is more what is it that
you really as user so going back to this
morning real-world problems what is it
that you really want solved and then
near the technologies I can provide a
little bit of the tools analyzing the
data as you said and maybe provide
answers but I don't know what you want
to do with the you are the one who is
going to tell me then what to do with
those with with the the results of this
technology so I kind of now try to look
the other way around why is this useful
to solve which particular problems what
are the questions that you want me to
address so can I take a different tack
on this so Raj you may be absolutely
right but it may be too soon
to be asking that question if you think
back in the long history of Natural
Sciences say we all look upon Newton's
discovery of the laws of motion as a
huge huge event in the history of
mankind but let's face it he had Kepler
and and Copernicus and countless
observations from astronomers before him
which sort of built the foundational
empirical base upon which he could do
the science so if you are asking about a
meta science of cities we first need to
have a number of smart cities emerge
they may emerge and have similarities
and even more interestingly they may
have differences in the solutions and it
is in trying to understand whether those
differences are incidental or somehow
correlate it to the intrinsic nature of
those cities that is going to lead to
the insights so I would say your
questions are excellent questions
they're just a few decades too soon I'm
not going to be around when the answers
of being found out you may though I
actually am like Schrodinger right like
the DNA but because you know I've told
these many times when I was in New York
also and I actually believe that cities
are a system that is highly highly
constrained probably there is a lot of
uncertainty too but you know what when
you build this building
you create in our apartments there are
three bedroom apartments and then the
others are one-bedroom apartment and you
create these many seats on some
restaurant and you say that all job
starts at start at 9:00 a.m. you are
really creating the whole infrastructure
I mean you can you can't model it's just
the hard part is the complexity of this
model but notice that the freedom that
people have venus city giving the
structures that our society created on
top of us aren't minimal are minimal the
only thing that comes there is uncertain
is due to the weather which we cannot
yet control if the weather were like
completely stable we would know exactly
at what time we even have kids to drop
in school we have all to have lunch we
all get out of bananas in your house and
we have to go and buy more it all
traders gels which is right there when
there is not what is like flexible zero
I'm telling you if it weren't for the
processes there are physical I mean the
subways come all at the same time when
we are in Germany or even in New York
now in New York you have like in two
minutes comes the subway that's it in
two minutes the subways we all go in we
all go out it's like we are in this
machinery a city actually is a machinery
that is determining everything
oh look Lincoln Center even here Heinz
Hall is always at that time that's it
it's not that we can ask how today's at
7:30 tomorrow at 9:00 no row starts it
is time we all go into the garage at the
same time we all come out at the same
time we are all have like dinner before
the concert it's an amazing defined
process I tell you I would love to be
able to talk about a city as almost a
deterministic model with very little
variance with if we if we lock the
uncertainty of okay the person is
doesn't feel well and go home and
is rain today if we process it is like
kind of like variations 90% of the city
we can all say what's going to happen
and you know what it's not that like
look at the Carnegie Mellon don't we
have the all the classes started
sometime in that sometime you know you
know in gates the building is empty
comes 10 to noon when the classes end
whoops there you go
it's that's it in fact I was talking
with the professor he on the day that
she said I have to rush to that to the
restaurant at 11:45 that's it because
that's when she knows that there is no
going to be no line in these in this
restaurant because the students in
tomate yet so it's highly predictable we
can model and we should be able to
optimize that moddable City a city is a
model thank you and well in fact I agree
I think I think the idea is some part of
a science could be a model of how the
city works don't yeah I'd like to pick
up on something you said ma'am well in
your opening remarks because there's
cautions about the smart city you know
one caution is the big companies are in
there Cisco IBM Ericsson whatever it
might be
are they driving the use case as Andrew
said earlier are we thinking about as
Jose said she'll be asking what the
cities need Andrew talked about the
Orwellian future I mean where's the
privacy where's all of that and my point
about people versus technology but you
raised another caution that I wanted to
pick up on is responsibility and
culpability if we get to the point where
we have these predictive algorithms and
a public if something goes wrong the
public officials say it wasn't me it was
the algorithm and so they're off the
hook so could you respond to that
anybody won't respond to that well few
thoughts about these you know that this
type of question it's not only like a
question that comes from the human side
but from our algorithm side is also the
pickled because somehow AI and machine
learning have been in the business of
solving problems for many years but not
telling anyone how they are solved so
our algorithms do this search and we
kind of like our masters of doing search
efficiently but nothing of the search
process is saved nothing of how the
weights may change is saved so a lot of
our algorithms are about outputting a
solution so currently to actually be
able to support that solution with some
rationale on which examples were used or
which data made a difference and
sensitivity analysis and dependency
models it's also part of our research
and I think that the cities and the fact
that we are developing computer science
and machine learning and engineering
solutions for people made now this
question much more relevant than in the
future because if someone asks you
what's the next prime number you dump
the next prime number and nobody asks
you why you know you just actually trust
the Machine but if you sign now these
you know this is like you cannot have a
credit card at all you are going to say
why so when you enter these disease that
is interaction between computer science
and computing and the social aspects
including the city these need for
interpretability and explanation is
needed now but that's from a technical
way we also challenge for us we are not
we don't have good math that explains
why the integral of these is this we are
not authorizing because of the chain
rule because of these we don't have that
so it's for the next many years to come
a challenge to change these the way that
computers process data to be responsible
to give answers to alex has a responses
to thank you very much I think part of
the question that you ask certainly
speaks to desire for transparency or
explain ability but the other point I
want to address is this idea of
accountability who is accountable and I
think that brings us outside of the
realm of policy and really into law and
there have been initiatives that we can
turn to for instance in the European
Union later this year the gdpr will be
too
in effect which starts to at least
introduce not legally binding
legislation but something to that effect
requiring some sort of contestability of
algorithmic decisions at least decisions
that are made entirely by an algorithmic
system not by a human some review
process and also something that's not
entirely in law but some form of a right
to explanation that when consequential
decisions are made about people there
needs to be some accountability and we
can't just throw up our hands and say
the Machine told me to do it or the
machine said your loan is denied but
that I think speaks to a lot of legal
concerns and I don't know that the
United States is quite there yet and
planning out that part of the landscape
good thank you one more question from
Dan sorry Dan Megan and then we'll
briefly something I'll give you two two
questions one is comparatively easier
than the other I think the one that's
comparatively easier is suppose mayor de
Blasio said I'd like you to give me a
prediction of how a congestion pricing
policy might affect traffic in New York
City okay that's a comparatively easier
one and then the harder one I think
would be is if I can't remember who the
mayor was in 1980 but doing the eighties
but if that mayor were to say please
give me a prediction of what New York
City is going to be like now the way New
York City has evolved over the even over
the last 30 years I think is
unimaginable dude
anybody in this room and I think it's a
reflection of the complexity of
you large human systems but just do you
actually think that maybe there weren't
some folks that were envisioning like
grant Oliphant was talking about this
morning of a Pittsburgh with a cultural
district back when I grew up that was
not the cultural district and to imagine
that being a cultural district many of
us might not have but there were some
folks that maybe had that vision having
a vision of where a city should evolve
to is different than being able to make
predictions the way it would evolve I
would assert that nobody could have
imagined New York City what it is like
now even compared to 1990 and then
certainly not even doing that those if
anybody wanted to take that computer
science colleagues did well I mean the
impact of technology is varied on social
social infrastructure and social
behavior is actually quite hard who
would have thought just five years ago
that the creation of Facebook could have
affected a presidential election okay so
you know there's a there's a famous
phrase used for this which is the Black
Swan and I think technology of the kind
that a number of us work on results in
these kinds of black swans from the
point of view of human behavior and I
think it's very hard to predict by
definition what the consequences of
black swans are you get the last word
jose before I wrap up the back was
going to do the opposite the opposite
question
and I'm reminded of the movie
Truman's show everything is so
predictable so enjoyable why not try to
predict the future precisely and you'll
be so happy one word but your question
is about actually exactly I love The
Truman Show I think we should all be
like but I tell you something
it's a multi-modal problem it's a lot of
things need to be taken to account to do
a better prediction if you take into
account like also the culture movement
in ah in New York who knows so the hard
part is that it's so many factors and so
to wrap up thank you to the first join
me in thanking all these panels they've
done a great job so for example we hear
that a science of CMU might start to
look like a model that has many
different phenomenas from different
Sciences influencing the interactions in
that model and influencing the
predictions we as young as Manuela
pointed out we must be able to predict
not only what we know if will happen if
nothing is changed but we need to be
able to predict the counterfactuals
the what-ifs are going to be very
important to even come close to Dan
Megan's concern so if we make these
changes as visionaries thirty years ago
do we get to where we are today and what
are the variables that cause us to maybe
get there and not get there and finally
I think we heard that we must be able to
use our science to help cities answer
the questions they have so I was going
to ask as a Dean of the engineering
college does that mean we maybe start
out taking more of an engineering
approach the way the Boilermakers first
designed the boilers for the engines
they didn't have the science they
proceeded forward and as things were
blowing up they've
figured they needed to figure out how to
better under understand and develop
science around that to keep them from
blowing up well I think we're probably
in a middle middle ground there we're
building the laboratories Metro 21 is
trying to build a laboratory that will
get start to collect sensing of all
sorts of different phenomena and from
that will emerge models of parts of the
city that will soon become maybe able to
be connected and then we will do
continue a process of trying things
instrumenting measuring and modifying
and I think by that way we'll be able to
come up with a very multi physics
compositional what did you call
compositional science based model of how
cities may actually be behaving and and
be somewhat predictive so thank you for
your sage advice in your discussion here
thank you all for your questions and we
now move on to the next session thank
you
[Applause]